if I say like what is it about an animal
a nonhuman animal that allows you to
kill them and torture them in fact and
put them through factory farm processes
like what is the what is the thing that
they have or the thing that they lack
that if a human were to have alter lac
you'd be ok with doing it to the human
as well like what is it is it
intelligence if it's intelligence then
can we throw people with under a certain
IQ into factory farms like probably not
well maybe it's maybe it's self
awareness it's like well is a dog
self-aware probably but well a pig is
just a self-aware as the dog is so why
aren't you this it's just about
consistency right if someone turns
around and says actually yeah I do think
it'd be a good idea to throw people with
an IQ under certain amount into factory
farms then I'd be like well at least
you'll be inconsistent I am joined by
Alex O'Connor otherwise known as cosmic
skeptic Alex welcome the show thank you
for having me it's a pleasure to have
you one will have a lot of your fans
tuning in I'm sure as well been a lot of
changes recently we've been talking
about booking this appointment in with
yourself for a little while and the
topics I want you to talk about have
moved as the as the years gone on first
things first
you've recently become vegan that's
right yeah can you tell us the story
behind that please yeah sure well I mean
you say recently it's recent in the long
scheme of things but it's been maybe
four or five months now and coming on
half a year soon but for a very long
time I've been thinking about it and
when you talk about philosophy and for
some reason atheism it seems to lend
itself your audience will always kind of
say what do you think about this I've
always found it very strange someone
likes what you have to say on one topic
and they're desperate to hear on what
you have to say on brexit on veganism or
whatever it is and I've never quite
understood that it's like really
enjoying a footballer's commentary on a
game or something and say oh yeah but
what do you think about this political
issue it's like well that's not what I
do I do
philosophy of religion but people wanted
me to talk about veganism so I did it in
the past and you find yourself kind of
jumping through hoops and if you listen
to people like sam harris or someone
when they're asked about morality
especially because his veganism his
moral philosophy is based on suffering
someone says why aren't you a vegan and
he just kind of he just he answers like
a
petition you know he's like well we have
to you know we have to have an honest
conversation about the precepts of the
stuff and it's like man just just admit
that that you you know you should be a
vegan so I was kind of in that spot and
I was talking to friends and essentially
saying I'm pretty sure that veganism is
the moral thing to do but let me give
you some arguments against it and see
where we can go and it just didn't work
and then eventually I was like you know
what I'm gonna put out a video
essentially saying to people here are
the reasons for going vegan try and talk
me out of it and the main thing that got
me thinking about it was Peter singers
Burke Animal Liberation Peter singer is
probably the most important philosopher
in my life in terms of how he's changed
the way I think I mean there are lots of
atheist philosophers who I'd be more
closely associated to because that's
what I've spoken about but they were
more people who I listened to and
admired but they didn't really like like
overhaul the way that I'm living my life
Peter singer has done that completely
with animal rights and also his writings
on philanthropy so I read that and I
thought man this is this is this is big
this is a big problem and so I made the
video no one talked me out of it so I
went vegan it just kind of happened one
day I went cold turkey I was on a bus
and to work and I saw this cat across
the road and it got scared of the bus
but because I was on the bus it was like
it was looking at me and I saw this cat
like backing away in fear and I just
looked into its eyes and thought what
the hell am i doing so I went had a
vegan breakfast and then since then I
haven't had any animal products except
by accident every now and again but
that's basically how it happened we have
a co-host on a show Yousef who is from
Islamic background although he's not a
believer anymore and he refers to it as
being stealth porked when there's
accidentally some pork products in
whatever is that he's eating so I'm
guessing that you've come up with
stealth meat it well you know it's an
interesting debate actually what you
should do in situations like that like
it if you accidentally if a chef
accidentally put some cheese on it on a
meal so for instance the other day I had
some cheese on chips because I was with
a friend and we it was really late at
night and we ordered some chips from her
from a kebab place you know and like we
expressly just didn't say cheese and I
even said can I have some chips with
some sort of vinegar and nothing else no
sauce or anything he was like yeah sure
and they came just loaded with cheese
and we thought what the hell do we do
here if we give that back
then it's going in the bin there was no
one else around is about to close so it
was like we had to eat it or it gets
thrown away so we ate it because as far
as I'm concerned the sufferings already
been wasted it'll be a waste of it goes
in the bin it's a waste if it's used for
my sensory pleasure but at least the
pleasures somewhat maximized in that
situation as it stands
some people like when I spoke to a guy
called earthling aired a friend of mine
who makes a lot of vegan content on
YouTube he I asked him about this and he
said when that happens he wouldn't he
wouldn't touch it he he'd rather it went
to way so you'd rather tread in the
ocean or something just because he
doesn't see it as food anymore it's like
being so plastic in your meal or
something you would just you just
wouldn't be able to eat it but for me
because it's basically a philosophical
position like you say like I don't have
an aversion to it like I'm not gonna
throw up if you if you put a steak in
front of me like I did I see it the same
as I've always seen it just not in the
same moral light so if it were like
here's a steak it's gonna go to waste if
you don't eat it I wouldn't have a moral
problem with somebody eating it in that
circumstance where some vegans would do
you think that your particular stance
your lineage of entry into veganism is
typical I don't know of many people at
least publicly who've taken it from the
particular route that you have yeah yeah
I do I don't know because most of the
vegans that I know personally weren't
vegan until I went vegan and try to like
use it and we ended up all day together
you know the one the biggest the the
most popular way for people to become
vegan is by having friends who are vegan
like that's the most common way that
happens because you know your share
meals with them or whatever they'll show
you how it's done you realize how easy
it is but I think it kind of it depends
what type of person you are like I spend
a lot of time talking to to people who
are interested in the same things as me
they're interested in philosophy and if
you're interested in philosophy then
when you have an argument presented to
you that can be really important for you
that can really change the way you think
but if you go to the average person on
the street they're not going to be as
affected by that as if you just show
them some footage so I think it's
probably the case that the majority of
people who are vegan either were
convinced by a friend or they looked at
the footage online and that kind of
stuff
I think it's kind of an emotive response
because even for me after all like I
became convinced at the philosophical
argument and then I had that experience
with the cat that finally made me that
was the day that it happened you need
that kind of emotional motivation like
ethics doesn't work unless it has some
kind of grounding in in your in your
emotions in your feelings so I think it
needs both but I would probably say that
yeah it might be quite unusual
especially because like I don't see many
vegans kind of going unconvinced of this
someone talked me out of it you know
they just kind of they have like an
emotional response in they say man I'll
never eat meat again this is horrible
all they'll do it for the environment I
think that's actually probably the big
one at the moment the most I wouldn't be
surprised to learn that the people who
are going vegan now are mostly doing it
for environmental purposes because
you're beginning to see this big kind of
backlash of people who were all crazy
about the environment I mean it's the
big issue at the moment everyone's going
crazy about the environment in the
oceans and people are just saying well
okay so you're gonna you're gonna stop
using plastic straws to save the fish
but you won't stop eating fish to save
the fish and people are beginning to
wake up and realize that oh the Amazon
rainforest is burning okay why is that
happening well it's got a lot to do with
the fact that people that eating too
much beef oh oh well okay well let's
stop using plastic no no did did you not
hear me like if we stop eating so much
beef then the environment the
environmental quite the problem in the
environment it practically disappears if
we weren't beacon tomorrow now like yeah
but there are there are other it's like
no look you want to care about this well
you don't and that's why I get annoyed
with people like the extinct in
rebellion group who are you know
blocking Parliament blocking the roads
in London and things I understand the
direct action is needed sometimes you
know I can get behind a bit of civil
disobedience but my god if this is
important enough for you to bring London
traffic to a standstill and stop
aeroplanes from taking off then it's
important enough for you to choose
something else on the menu like come on
I can't give anyone in time of day who
knows some people don't know and that's
fine but if you know how important the
agricultural industry is to the rise of
climate change and you're still one of
these the steadfast campaign is getting
people to do
everything they can and and saying
you're not allowed to travel you know
Parliament isn't allowed to concentrate
on anything else this is the most
important thing in the world but you're
still eating red meat and you're still
eating fish then I I just don't know
what to say to you people picking their
morality piecemeal I want this bit but I
don't want the other bit
I want the bit that doesn't
inconvenience me and makes me look
really cool to my friends but I don't
want the thing that requires me to learn
some new recipes in the kitchen exactly
that and you know I don't people to get
me wrong I'm not saying that they
shouldn't be campaigning I'm just saying
that if they if they're campaigning that
much then they should kind of take it to
its logical conclusion it's like if
someone were campaigning to to end end
the form of slavery but but supporting
another form of slavery it's like it's
not a bad thing that you're campaigning
to end this one with slavery but you've
got to be consistent about this if you
want people to take you seriously like
if you want the people who were
interested in the philosophy behind your
movement if you want people who are
interested in the arguments behind your
movement to take you seriously you have
to be consistent it's going to be too
easy
for people who are who are climate
sceptics to turn around and say well if
you care so much about the environment
the why aren't you doing anything about
your diet and you're just kind of you
you'd be stumbling around and you won't
really know what to say so I think yeah
you've got it you've got to be
consistent too if only just to avoid the
kind of criticism that you're gonna
receive if you don't do that yeah I've
got some party friends we run our own
Club nights it's been my job for the
last 13 years and in the clubbing
industry there are there's an increasing
woke movement which is very very
interesting and recently one of my
friends posted something online talking
about woke promoters there's quite a lot
of them down south people that are going
vegan and vegetarian but noticed the
fact that they were concerned at the
plight of animals and factory farming
and stuff like that what we're more than
happy to put 60 quid into a drug dealers
hand to get some cocaine which had been
made off the back of children in Brazil
and in Mexico and all of the sort of
drug gangs so I think you're right
there's layers and levels to this sort
of a thing so one of the things that I
wanted you to present to the listeners
was could you give us the arguments that
most compel
to go vegan yeah well it's more I mean I
kind of look at in the reverse I say
that if you're gonna do something that
involves causing suffering then you have
to be able to justify it and so it was
more the arguments in favor of eating
meat disappeared I mean if you want an
argument against eating meat or let's
say because eating meat intrinsically
isn't wrong but I kind of I use the word
the phrase like eating meat to be
synonymous with the mistreatment of
animals although that's probably an
unfair thing to do in many ways but
sometimes that's what my vocabulary does
but if you want an argument against
torturing animals then it's like most
people will be content if you just say
well would you be okay if I talked you
to dog I mean how would you feel if you
just saw a dog being beaten on the
street like like what would you do and
they'll say well that's awful and it's
like well you're already convinced that
like we don't actually need to get into
the meta epoch of why it's wrong to make
animals suffer I just have to show you
that torturing a dog is not morally
different from torturing a pig some
people might say well I would wouldn't
have a problem with that like why should
I care about the dog in which case it
gets a bit more difficult you have to
kind of present a meta Attica position
about suffering which I know it gets
complicated but the main way that I get
people to go vegan philosophically
speaking is with an argument from
consistency if you're against racism and
sexism you should probably be against
speciesism - and that doesn't mean
seeing people as equal that's one of the
big things that Peter Singer pointed out
he said that like the races aren't equal
sexes aren't equal we have loads and
loads of differences we have different
proportions we have different languages
and cultures and different different all
sorts of things like nobody's equal and
even in terms of skill like different
people have different skill levels and
intrinsically they have different
strengths and weaknesses he said you
know if political equity if political
equal treatment was based on actual
equality of people then there would be
no equality there would be no basis for
it he says it's not like the being
anti-racist isn't saying all races are
equal it's saying that despite our
differences we're all worth the same
morally and it's the same thing with
animals except you don't have to say
that we're worth the same you just have
to say that we're we're afforded the
same moral
the same kind of when you kind of
included in the thought process at least
like if you're in favor of equality of
the sexes you don't have to give men
abortion rights because I doesn't make
any sense in the same way you can be in
favor of treating animals with respect
and giving them kind of an equal
consideration is the phrase that Peter
Singer uses doesn't mean we gonna let
them vote doesn't mean we're gonna make
them treat them as though they're the
same as humans or you can have the same
moral worth as humans it just means that
we treat them as much with as much as
they deserve so if I say like what is it
about an animal a nonhuman animal that
allows you to kill them and torture them
in fact and put them through factory
farm processes like what is the what is
the thing that they have or the thing
that they lack that if a human were to
have alter Lac you'd be okay with doing
it to the human as well like what is it
is it intelligence if it's intelligence
then can we throw you can we throw
people with under a certain IQ into
factory farms like probably not well
maybe it's maybe it's self awareness
it's like well there's a dog self-aware
probably but well a pig is just a
self-aware as the dog is so why aren't
you there it's just about consistency
right if someone turns around and says
actually yeah I do think that if we I do
think it'd be a good idea to throw
people with an IQ under certain amount
into factory farms then I'd be like well
at least you're being consistent right
the conversation is strange views but
yes you have you being honest yeah I'm
no longer saying now here's way should
be vegan it's here's why you should not
want to kill people who were done right
yeah the conversation shifts but if
somebody is on the same page which most
people are it sounds absurd to compare
like racism to the treatment of animals
but if anything like if you quantify
suffering if what you care about is
suffering and I think most atheists at
the very least do care about suffering
is the basis of their morality then
animals can feel suffering just as we
can it's in different ways like they
might feel they might not feel the same
kind of fears and anxieties as we do
they don't have anxiety over debt for
instance as a very human specific
suffering but when it comes to physical
pains and things like these things might
be comparable right we can't do it in
practice but if you think pain can be
quantifiable which some P
do some people don't then you might say
well yeah racism is awful but with the
state of racism at the moment in the
United States like the amount of pain is
not as much as the amount of pain in the
animal industry you might agree with
that you might not but they are
comparable at the very least like it can
be analogous and if you think about the
sheer numbers involved like this is I
mean Peter got in a lot of trouble years
ago for doing this Holocaust on your
plate campaign where they made a
comparison saying like 12 million people
perished in the Holocaust between you
know the years of world war two between
39 and 45 at 12 million were killed and
then they just point out that this like
the same number of non-human animals are
tortured and killed every single hour in
the United States alone for food and
people were like how the hell could you
possibly compare them it's like well
well think about that for a second even
if you think that one is way worse than
the other just think about the numbers
they're like 50 billion animals being
tortured and killed every year not for
war not an office and social progress
because people think they taste nice
like that's insane right and so if you
begin to make people see that animals
can feel suffering and you begin to make
them see how that's analogous to our own
suffering like evolutionarily speaking
rationally speaking I have no reason not
to be a racist I mean I'm never gonna
I'm never gonna suffer from racism like
in in a society in a society that's
dominated by white people I mean I'm
never gonna suffer let's say from from
anti black racism right no it's not
going to be a problem for me so what why
would I be against it's a rational thing
it's a moral thing it's like I I tap
into my empathy I tap into a societal
cohesion all of these kinds of things
and I realize that suffering is bad no
matter who's suffering from it and if I
can do the same thing for them then I
can do the same thing for non-human
animals as well it is a compelling
argument it is a compelling argument I
think speciesism is definitely what most
people are drawing that line at it's an
extension of us just being tribal the
same way that he had if it would have
protected us a long time ago does
consciousness and suffering a day today
go hand in hand I think it depends how
you depending consciousness like the
only thing that I care about when it
comes to morality is the ability to feel
pain
and the ability to feel pleasure which
someone like singing would point out is
kind of predicated on or is the basis
for preference like if if a creature has
such thing as preference then they then
they have moral worth at least some
miniscule level of model moral worth so
if you have some creature that somehow
conscious but doesn't feel pleasure and
pain then I wouldn't consider them as
part of the moral framework because if
you didn't feel pleasures and pains like
you'd essentially just be a vegetable
it's its preferences that motivate
action you only do things because you
want to do them like that that's what
made a base action desire metaphase
action and in order to have desire you
need to have some conception of pleasure
and pain because desire is predicated
upon pleasure itself so without pleasure
and pain I don't know if consciousness
can even make sense but if it can then
that's not the important thing for me
it's just the pleasure and pain I'm
sitting down with Niall on Monday to
discuss his new book indestructible and
in that he cites a couple of studies
that he suggests show that there isn't
such a thing as pleasure chasing there
is only pain avoidance hmm
and that was an interesting eye-opener
for me just thinking about the way that
we live our lives and what it is that we
go towards and apply is even more
pressure to avoiding discomfort avoiding
suffering as you're saying here so there
must be a spectrum of suffering and of
consciousness and there must be a bottom
end there must be a line where animals
no longer are animals and become
vegetables there's some animals that are
more responsive to stimuli some plants
that more responsive to stimuli than
animals are like coral or limpets how
where do we how do you draw the line
there why does the rubber meet the road
with that so it's all about the
maximization of pleasure or I'd rather
frame it actually as your guest would in
in in the terms of minimization of
suffering because a lot of philosophical
pessimists have so for instance Arthur
Schopenhauer pointed out in his most
famous essay he essentially said look
all these philosophers have it totally
wrong everyone thinks that pleasure is
like the affirmative thing and pain is
like the absence of pleasure or
something along that lines it's like no
that
the most real thing the most active
thing is pain and all pleasure is just
some kind of negation of pain it's all
about avoiding pain or whether that be
physical pain or like philosophical pain
and then and not not being able to
understand the world and absurd is and
Camus said that all of the meaning of
life is essentially just finding excuses
not to kill yourself like that all but
life that's all that life is you know I
think it makes sense to view the world
in that way and if we do then we have to
we have to figure out the calculation
that's most going to minimize suffering
a way to think about it how you would
frame the world like where you would
draw the line whether you whether you'd
be okay with us killing plants and trees
or whatever is to apply Jean rules is
principle the the veil of ignorance john
john rules should have been a vegan
because he quite famously came up with
this analogy that if you didn't know if
you were going to be born black or white
or lower class or upper class or
whatever it was like you didn't know
what social characteristics you've had
but you're about to be born into the
world you have no idea where you're
gonna be but you're gonna be born let's
say like in the United States for
instance design society before you get
into that society so design society
before you know where you're going to be
in it so he concluded you probably want
to have a capitalist economy so that if
you have an opportunity to make money
you can do so when you can be free to
make as much money as you can but with
some kind of social safety net so that
if you're born into into areas with no
economic opportunity you'll have some
help it's like that would be fair
because you realize that that's that's
gonna better your chances now do just do
the same thing but apply it to you don't
know what thing you're going to be you
could be a tree you could be a bush you
could be a chair you could be a pig you
could be a human and design society the
question is would you have an
agricultural industry in that society
of course you bloody wouldn't like
chickens outnumber humans three to one
you've got three times more chance of
being a chicken it you're gonna be ok
with those odds or are you gonna say no
no let's not have KFC in this society
and I say to you well no you don't
understand because you could be born a
human and you and you'll get so much
pleasure from eating chicken and if you
are born a chicken like chickens have so
much less intelligence and and you eat
you won't be smart you won't you won't
you would feel the pain as much like
be like no that's that's insane I'm not
gonna run that risk I would rather have
the chance of being a human and have to
not eat chicken then run the risk of
being a chicken in the animal industry
right so now the question would be would
you be okay being a tree or a plant it's
like well as far as I'm concerned they
don't feel pain so I probably wouldn't
have a problem with that but the thing
is let's say that plants can feel pain
this is an important thing because
people often bring it up as a bit of a
meme it's like it's like when an atheist
someone asks an atheist like but but
where do you find your meaning or
something in every 80's just rolls their
eyes like how have you not like this is
just ridiculous
it's the same thing with the plants
thing people always bring it up it's
like but plants can feel pain and the
vegans go off for God's sake and what
most of them say is they go no they
can't feel pain
that's ridiculous shut up what I say is
okay let's say they can feel pain you
understand that the vast majority of
plants that are that are destroyed are
not fed to humans they're fed to
livestock right like where do you think
your protein gets its protein from
they're eating plants as well if you
think if you think plants can can suffer
then the best way to minimize plants
being killed is to go vegan because then
we won't be feeding them to the
livestock so even if plants can feel
pain the way to minimize that pain is to
go vegan like veganism doesn't eliminate
suffering you're still killing animals
you're still you're still destroying
land to grow crops and things like that
it's just about minimizing it because
that's already happening right now in
order to grow crops that we then feed to
cows which we then kill and eat like
just cut out the middleman and we'll
reduce the suffering even even more so
you're never gonna be able to eliminate
suffering so if plants can feel pain
then that would just be a sorry fact of
existence but it would be one that we
can manage by still going vegan yeah
would you say that moving forward if you
were able to create the equivalent of a
philosophical zombie animal some meat
that's being grown in a chess test tube
or whatever it might be
what would your stance be on that if you
can't feel suffering then no problem
I said no suffering no problem do you
think that most vegans hold that view I
wouldn't I wouldn't know I mean a lot of
vegans I've spoken to most vegans I've
spoken to who didn't go vegan at the
same time as me for the same reasons
give up give a lot of weight to to
preference
so I was speaking someone in London
recently I I do some events sometimes
and it's always nice because people will
come pew senior Channel so you know you
get an opportunity to meet people and
I'm very used to people coming up and
saying you know I like the video she did
on atheism I like this moral that can we
talk about that the the nature of
morality or something but I kind of
forgot that I'd done the veganism thing
so recently and if someone someone comes
up to me these people come up to me and
say hi weird weird some of your your
vegan viewers and I was like wow this is
the first time this is this is our ha
I've never had this before so as I was
talking to them about it and they were
talking about preference the idea being
that because animals want to live they
have a preference to live we should
respect that just intrinsically like if
you were to go and kill an animal behind
its back with no suffering would that be
a problem and I'm of the opinion that
it's all about pleasure and pain so I
would say like the preference alone
isn't enough to say that you shouldn't
kill that animal and and they had a
problem with that they were like no that
there is some moral worth to preference
you're getting rid of potential pleasure
that kind of thing I reject that because
for instance if you're talking about
potential pleasure having worth then you
get into a whole problem with like
abortion and I'm not just talking about
the normal debate surrounding abortion
I'm talking like the idea that you you
doing this podcast instead of going and
having sex right now
she is preventing potential pleasure but
that's that's just about we just get
we're gonna mean that's the excuse I
always use right that's that's an absurd
argument obviously and you know I
wouldn't want anyone to take that
argument seriously but that just
demonstrates my potential pleasure at
least on its own isn't enough to justify
it so they say for instance well then
would you be okay with going in and
killing a human being without them
feeling any suffering and without them
knowing it was coming and it's like okay
I'm gonna need to qualify this but yes
and and the eyebrows the back of the
head it's like the reason that wouldn't
work is because firstly the very fact
that that we would be aware in our moral
system that it's okay to do that would
cause panic and suffering so even just
allowing that as part of the moral
zeitgeist would lower suffering which
means even even allowing that to be
thought of as moral is
moral in itself so we shouldn't do it
but besides there's so many more
complications with things like friends
and family and then the effect on
society and things like that that don't
apply to to chickens and pigs like if
you take one chicken out of the out of a
herd of a hundred and kill it without it
knowing without feeling any suffering
there's not going to be any real social
implications for that although there are
there are arguments to say that the
animals the social animals will really
notice like like I had this big
discussion with armed in the VAR b and
and some other youtubers in London
recently about chicken depression there
was a friend of ours who who knows
someone who runs a runs a chicken farm
and he was talking about a know I think
chickens can can get like depressed like
you see them when when their family are
killed like they get upset and almonds
like that that's really good chickens
can't get depressed and we were arguing
about chicken depression and and so so
some people would say that even if you
go and kill an animal without knowing
that's going to be a problem because
it's friends a family will know but then
again the reason that would be wrong
wouldn't be because of the intrinsic
removal of the preference of the animal
you're killing but because of the
suffering of the other animal a so it
still comes down for suffering exactly
yeah so it's never the preference alone
that I think has a moral worth it's
always the suffering and I think that's
where I would differ from many other
vegans who give more they don't my
second kind of sanctity of life approach
they're like we need to respect life or
they they take a kind of animals aren't
here for our use kind of thing it's just
like a philosophical deontological
principle for me it's like there's no
special thing about it like veganism
isn't it isn't a special thing in and of
itself for me it's just a derivative of
my general moral principle of minimizing
suffering like I'm the same reason I'm a
vegan for the same reason that I'm not a
racist it's it's like it just kind of
follows naturally right it's not a not a
specific thing in its own regard like
like being young being an atheist
doesn't really fall in that category but
that's a whole different area of
discussion it's a whole different
argument but the veganism thing is just
just well under this umbrella of all
kind of all moral principles that I hope
the same reason that I wouldn't be to
dog on the street the same reason that
I'm against domestic violence the same
reason I'm against racism or whatever it
is like it's all part of the same thing
it's all just about minimizing suffering
how do animals that kill other animals
fit into this paradigm have you thought
about that yeah I haven't
we'll say you know you don't judge the
lion for dining on the dining on the
gazelle so why should I be judge for
doing it it's like okay well lions also
will will murder other lion populations
and impregnate the females to repopulate
the the pride with their own children
and murder the children that exist there
already should we do that as well like I
said hard for us to roll that one
forward yeah you might base your moral
your moral framework on that of wild
animals I think more highly of humans
then then that you know like in the same
way that if you had a severely disabled
child who had a tumor pressing against
the part of their brain that dealt with
rational thought and they and they kind
of smacked someone in the face you
wouldn't hold them morally responsible
for it it's but just because we don't
hold that child morally responsible for
doing things that we would consider
wrong we can't then turn around and do a
moral things to them right so just
because we don't hold like you could
take an intensely disabled person who
just was totally out of control of any
of their actions we wouldn't hold them
morally responsible for trying to hit us
but we can still hold ourselves morally
responsible for trying to hit them in
the same way we don't hold animals
morally responsible for for raping each
other or for killing each other or
eating each other that doesn't mean we
can do it to them as well I mean are we
okay to have sex with animals some
people would say yes that's an interest
that's another interesting discussion
actually because like it's like you know
I I would I wouldn't argue that and I
don't have to take this route because
I'm a vegan but if you're okay with
putting animals in factory farms and I
don't understand how you could be
against people having sex with them
because then at least there's a chance
they might enjoy it and even if they
don't enjoy it it can't be much worse
than being put through a factory calm so
like to keep to the question yeah the
answer the answer that I would give is
my moral system is based on what I
consider to be rational thought
processes not trying to mirror the
animal kingdom there's no might makes
right there's no appeal to nature or
anything like that it's just about
minimization of suffering I think that
difference between the animals for
eating in animals for sex you've come up
with there probably strikes a chord with
what most people what would the reason
that most people choose to go vegan
more visceral emotive response right
because when you think about the killing
you're somehow removed it's not you
that's doing it you're just doing the
eating whereas with the sex like you're
there anyone anyone who's watched Black
Mirror yeah it's really strange though
isn't it it's like people had this
people had this weird aversion like if
it came out in the newspaper that that
some farmer had been serially raping his
pigs people would be like that's
disgusting it's like okay so you were
okay with this person like torturing
them skinning them putting a bolt
through their brain but as soon as they
put their dick in it like oh come on
like what are you doing it's the same
thing when people I it's like work
reservation said in his in his memoir he
he was sorta chrisbehrens wrote a memoir
I wrote read a book a biography of
Thomas Jefferson who famously owned very
many slaves including Sally Hemings who
is believed to have sexually soldered
and having a child with and and he
pointed out that historians are quick to
kind of defend Jefferson and say no no
he didn't he didn't sexually assault
Sally Hemings and they get kind of upset
by the idea that this this hero of
American history turns out that he just
has sexually assaulted some woman and
Hitchens is like oh but they were okay
with the whole owning her like they were
they were okay with her with him owning
this woman as proper bird technically
but the moment is suggested that he
tries to have sex with them like it
suddenly becomes this horrible thing and
accompany their hero has been stained in
this way it's like come on give me a
break it and I think it's kind of that
that's analogous to the same thing with
with having sex with animals it's like
if you think it's bad to have sex with a
horse or a pig then maybe you are giving
pigs moral worth maybe you do care about
their suffering and if you do care about
their suffering then my god stop buying
McDonald's it's people taking their
moral virtues piecemeal again isn't it
it's picking what they want from from
different areas so what do you think
what strikes me and the thing that I've
thought when I watched your your first
video a meat eaters case for veganism
which will be linked in the show notes
below if you just want to see what alex
is talking about really cool video what
struck me with that was the fact that
you then decided on the basis of quite a
cerebral approach to veganism
that you would commit because you wanted
to live in line you wanted your life to
live in line with your moral your moral
standing I think that to me
that friction in the system or that
slippage in the system is probably where
people don't make the jump they think
well okay compelling argument Alex like
you know yeah maybe you're right
maybe right about that but I just can't
be asked yeah then essentially the
question is is why be moral and that's a
difficult question to answer that's a
whole different ballgame it's like
people will tell me it's but it's the
one question that I can't really answer
very well it's the one kind of
impenetrable impenetrable boundary is
when people say yeah okay I accept that
it's the moral thing to do but I'm just
an immoral person it's like all I can
really do is tell you how to be moral
like all the earth that that sounds
incredibly itchy and self-righteous that
I mean all I can tell you what what I
mean by that is all I can tell you is
what I philosophically believe to be the
moral thing to do right that's what I
mean by that I can't really tell you why
you should be moral there are
philosophical arguments to do that but
all I'm saying is if you want to be
moral this is what I think this is how I
think it should be achieved right the
question of why should I be moral why
should I be be asked is like I don't
know but what if you would the way that
I usually approach these people as I say
okay let's say you are having a
conversation with someone who was a
racist or a neo-nazi or something like
that and they said you know what that's
a good point maybe you know maybe Jews
are all right after all maybe maybe the
moral thing to do is to not be
anti-semitic but I guess I'm just an
immoral person it's like what do you
think well who is this but I you think
they were insane or something and that's
the thing like people when you talk to
people about veganism like the
conversation usually ends with them kind
of going like yeah Wow
oh man you make something you make some
good points cool yeah but the bacon
though are you kidding me like this
isn't just some kind of like interesting
philosophical musing right this is this
is the most important moral issue of our
time it's like it's it's is it like I'm
nervous laughter that you're just kind
of laughing off like oh yeah good point
yeah it's like think about this
seriously come on like how
you feel if you were living in a society
and you were turning around and saying
guys how the hell are we owning people
as slaves right now this needs to end
and someone goes like oh man the good
point but look on there yeah it's like
it's like hold on but you can see and
it's the same thing it's like people
turn around go but but like so you don't
own slaves and you're like yes and
they're like but but but where do you
get your cotton it's like well what are
you talking about it's like wait but
you're vegan so where do you get your
protein the same the same place that
your protein gets your protein from like
it's just absurd and it's like these
people have never thought about it
before and most of them haven't ever
thought about it before because it's not
something that's that's talked about in
mainstream philosophy like if you think
about how important the moral issue
actually is it's something that in the
future will be will be one of the
biggest political issues of our time but
can you imagine Boris Johnson and Jeremy
Corbyn going at each other talking about
the nuances of the ethics of factory
farming I don't think I don't think it's
even imaginable but like they would do
it on almost any other issue they do it
on on disability benefits they do it on
the NHS they'd and it's like many of the
issues that are talked about regularly
in Parliament are nowhere near as
important as the suffering and torture
of sent of over 50 billion sentient
creatures every single year but it just
seems absurd to suggest that that would
be something that would be talked about
in Parliament but that just goes to show
how utterly unthinking we are when it
comes to this area of ethics it's like
our biggest ethical blind spot the
people people just it's not like people
don't know it's there but it's staring
us in the face and we have to kind of do
is just it's just readjust your site a
little bit it doesn't take much more
than that it's not like it's not like
something that people think is totally
totally okay and would fully defend it's
just you just need to start thinking
about it that's it and there's no wait
like if you saw a book on the shelf for
instance this is a point that's made it
there's a book called eating animals
should we stop I can't remember who it's
by but he made this point he was like in
the introduction or something he says I
bet you assume what my conclusion is
here like the book title just says
should we stop eating animals right yeah
that's all it says but
I bet you you've already assumed that
I'm gonna conclude that yeah we should
stop haven't you now why is that like
it's probably because you know that aim
one who's given it enough thought to
write a book about it has probably
become convinced that it's wrong to do
people know that if you think about it
enough then you'll become convinced that
it's wrong they're just not willing to
do the thinking and I wasn't willing to
do it either but the moment that I
committed to it like you just have to go
vegan and it's a lot easier than people
think it is it's so easy and the more
people do it the easier it gets still I
wonder what the equivalent success ratio
would be if the the government employed
Alex O'Connor cosmic skeptic to do the
marketing campaign for pro veganism
versus the more visceral response of
PETA like yours it would be different
sort of delivery and definitely some
different imagery I think so I I
wouldn't I wouldn't really trust myself
as a as a campaign I go toe to toe with
a lot of vegans I argued with Peter
Singer about this I argue with earthing
out about this I argue with non vegans
like are me Navabi about this the
essentially thick so things things that
are like good in terms of progress
that'll like politically good moves so
for instance in a lot of the colleges at
Oxford
they have like meatless Mondays in the
halls right if they have like it's
straight off the bite it's good
marketing
yeah well that's it it's all supposed to
be very fun and friendly on everything
and people people I've argued with
people about this because they they
assume that I'm gonna be all for like if
my college were like we're gonna start
doing meatless Mondays people would
think that I'd be a will in favor of
that like I can't put my name behind a
campaign like that that's why I wouldn't
want to run a vegan campaign because
technically that is reducing animal
suffering but I can't put my name behind
giving up meat on Mondays for the same
reason that as an abolitionist in the
1800s I wouldn't want to have put my
name behind a campaign that says how
about you give up your slaves on the
weekend
let them have let them have a few days
off like that's not what I'm going for
here like I think this is wrong and
needs to stop that that if I want to be
ethically consistent I have to advocate
for that position
people would call that a kind of
absolutism or fundamentalism well maybe
that's the best way to describe it but
in the same way that you're probably an
absolutist or a fundamentalist when it
your opposition to human slavery you
probably wouldn't accept compromises
you'd say you've got to stop doing this
now like full stop there's no excuse for
this so it is a difficult position as
well that's why I wouldn't consider
myself an activist and and wouldn't do
much activism along those kinds of
progressive means but I don't wanna
hinder people who are doing that because
like I say it is technically reducing
the suffering but I can't be the one to
be in charge of that like that's just
from all different angles right coming
at ya I'm your particular stance which
is quite cerebral coming out from this
more emotive this will response stance
and then this I suppose a habitual slow
habitual move where use well look you
got away with Monday you got away with
without me on Monday look what now yeah
how about if we do Tuesday yeah exactly
well you know I I consider like I think
about moral progress and you kind of
like you say you have to have all the
components if you think about like the
American Revolution you know you needed
the you needed the Jefferson to draft
the document you needed the Washington
to be the emotive leader but you also
needed the Thomas Paine who wrote the
essay and said no no like forget this
forget this representation nonsense
we're gonna we're gonna be independent
like at the time of the revolution
nobody really wanted independence they
just wanted a bit of representation in
Parliament and for the taxes to be to be
fair and Thomas Paine writes this essay
that says independence now no no
exceptions we're against here any full
stop and he put out the essay and no one
remembers Thomas Paine because he wasn't
the one who actually went on and made
the social progress happened because you
can't just do it like that but you need
it without that essay without that
philosophical push then the rest of it
wouldn't have happened and I think if
I'm gonna play a role in the liberation
of animals and I want it to be a kind of
like you say is sitting at a kind of
armchair philosophy I want to write the
essays that I want to write the essays I
want to do the arguments that that are
arguing for the absolutist moral
position so that the moderates and the
progressives have a philosophical basis
on which to base their political moves
but I couldn't take part in that side of
things really and you know maybe I will
in the future maybe that will change I
don't know but the thing that I don't
think can ever really change is my
conviction that this is the way forward
that this is what's not only what should
have
but what's going to happen especially
with people caring so much about the
environment right now it's not gonna
take much I think to convince the next
generation or maybe even the generation
after that that we need to stop eating
meat at the very least and probably all
dairy products just once you give up
meat it's not a big step so then also
give up dairy yeah I don't know I don't
know what role I play but I'm not big on
the whole the whole compromise thing
it's not for me
I think if if your philosophical
framework for this your conceptual
framework forms the foundation there is
a fair bit of weight on your shoulders
so you were all of the practice that
you've had of forming these arguments
and and having these discussions going
toe-to-toe with people hopefully will
stand you in good stead as you move
further forward so I wanted to get onto
your degree at Oxford you're doing
philosophy and theology is that correct
you just met - yes sure yes um what is
it like studying theology as an atheist
it's it's a it's fun you know
interesting so at Oxford at the very
least and I think in most theology
faculties now certainly in this country
and not theology faculties they've
rebranded themselves into theology and
religion faculties so you can you can
tailor your approach so you're not just
studying theology you're also studying
religion as a concept and for instance
the compulsory paper one of the
compulsory papers that all theology
students have to do is the figure of
Jesus through the centuries that's a
compulsory the compulsory theology paper
but it's very broad and my tutor gave us
a list of certain topics that we were
going to study and I looked at the
syllabus and said hold on we're doing
this this really boring dry mystic
Russian thing in in this week but I've
seen on the syllabus that you can if you
want to do the novels of Dostoevsky you
can do Jesus in those novels and I just
said can we do that instead and he goes
yeah sure whatever like that might not
be the same at other universities but
because of the tutorial system at Oxford
is very you can you can very much cater
it to what you want to do so it's not
like I have to sit around
like in in churchy situations and
learned about the nature of God you have
to do a bit at that like when we do
Athanasius he was one of the church
fathers we have to kind of engage with
the debate as to whether Jesus is fully
man and fully God or whether he's not
fully man and whether he's subordinate
of the Father but you can frame that not
as is Jesus subordinate to the Father
but did Athanasius think he was have
ordinate to the father and why not like
what was his biblical basis for that you
don't need to kind of actually think
it's real so you can study it from a
very detached secular perspective which
means that it's not like ironic or funny
that an atheist studies theology and I
think at this point probably more
atheist to studying theology than
religious people and you find that when
a religious person studying theology at
least in my experience a lot of the time
they're very devout and they're doing it
because they want to go into the
priesthood or because they want to
develop their theology like for their
for their personal benefit
whereas when an atheist studies that
they're doing it in a more kind of
academic framework but again that's fine
because you can do both of those things
you can tailor it you can do the reading
you want to do you can answer the
questions you want to answer so it's
it's actually not like you may as well
ask what it what it's like to be an
atheist studying history it's like yeah
there's a lot of religion in history but
it it's the same as studying it for any
for anybody else I think the same thing
is kind of happening with theology does
it feel very voyeuristic in a way the
fact that you have this detachment from
from the the belief and obviously you
had a fairly strong existing
understanding of theology going into or
at least based on your YouTube channel
it seemed like you did well there any
significant changes you've just
completed your first year have you found
yourself looking at your worldview
significantly differently in any areas
after well so far in on the theology
side of things on philosophy you had to
do moral philosophy and general
philosophy which doesn't really touch
religion but that like the moral
philosophy changed a lot what I think
about moral philosophy but we've
referenced to theology nothing much
changed but the papers weren't really
about that like next year we're doing
philosophy of religion so the thing that
I talked about on my channel mostly is
arguments for the existence of God and
things I don't talk so much about the
nature of Scripture or
or about the the pract the pragmatism of
certain religious traditions and things
that's not really my area I'm more about
the philosophy so if if my views were
can change on the things I talked about
it will probably happen next next year
but you kind of I don't know let me
think it's I guess you you realize it's
much less unified than you thought you
realized that one of the things that
really strikes me is that these people
who were who were heralded as
philosophical giants in the theological
history people like Aquinas or Augustine
or whatever or Athanasius and you read
their text and you you begin to kind of
realize this is just some guy this is
just this is just a person writing stuff
like it might be pretty good at writing
about it but but like it's just a person
just just writing something like they're
not there they're easy to engage with
you can engage with them in the same way
that you can engage with a modern
philosopher like it's not this kind of
untouchable ancient wisdom it's it's
just it's just writing it's just
philosophical argumentation it can be
engaged with in the same way but nothing
nothing's really changed on that front
no I don't think so
I had a I asked for some questions from
friends and some listeners to the
channel and one of them that came up was
really really good so I wanted to I
wanted to put this one to you as a nice
way to bookend this podcast what do you
think of they claimed an increase in
secularism in recent history has
resulted in a decrease in moral virtue I
don't think I don't think that's true
I think implicit in the question might
be if that's true then then if the
questions being asked in a kind of
challenging way it would be like if you
get rid of religion then you get rid of
moral virtue
well secularism isn't getting rid of
religion it's getting rid of religious
influence over government so okay I
think it is probably probably related
towards less religious following or
people increasingly becoming
non-religious or yes I suppose well so
there's those two different questions I
think that if if by getting rid of
religion we're getting rid of kind of
religious morality then I think that's
probably a good thing like if you
understand what religious morality often
in
then it's probably a good thing that
we're getting rid of it I don't I don't
believe like if you meet an atheist I
don't and and this isn't just me talking
I think this is probably just an INT you
were just an intuition that most
thinking people would have you wouldn't
assume that they're less moral now you
might assume that they have less of a
grounding for it if you're somebody who
believes if you're like a an ethical
subjectivist or you don't think morality
can exist without God you might think
that they can't ground their morality
but if you speak to Christians who make
the moral argument they say if you're an
atheist you have no basis for morality
and people always criticize them and say
and the Hitchens usually how dare you
say that we need moral permission to be
good how dare you say that we can't be
moral without God it's like that's not
what they're saying that they're saying
that you are being moral but that you
have no grounding for it and that you're
actually secretly kind of using the the
Christian worldview to buttress your
moral views I don't think that's true so
when I make moral arguments I I base
them on I I base them on secular
principles and I think that they hold up
like if you need religion to be moral
then let's investigate why that's the
case like why is it the case that if God
says you have to do something that
becomes the moral thing to do I mean
what is it about that
why should you do what God proclaims to
be good like is it because you want to
avoid hell well then it's just out of
suffering again like why do you want to
avoid hell what's wrong with going to
hell well it would it would hurt okay
like then your argument is the same as
mine do you think that God is just
speaking ontological truths with his
morality well commands can't have truth
value you can't say go over there is
that true or false as a command that's
not that there can't be true or false
like the same problems that you get with
trying to ground morality without God
you get the same problems trying to do
it in God like it's just a kind of
different it's a different ballgame but
the problems still arise so I don't
think it's true and and if it is the
case that if you get rid of religion the
moral virtue declines then that isn't a
problem with atheism that's probably
just a problem with the way that atheism
is being branded and the only people who
are really going there going around
convincing people that if you're an
atheist you can get away with immorality
and that if you're an atheist you don't
need to have moral virtue and if you're
an atheist you don't have to have moral
principles the only people who are who
are advocating that view are the
religious if it is the case that the
getting rid of religion is getting rid
of morality then that's because of the
way that the religious have painted
atheists morality if you speak to
atheists if we if we allow atheists to
speak about their morality and have
discussions that are popular about
grounding morality in a godless universe
then we wouldn't have that problem
because people would realize that we can
ground morality just as easily if not
better then then we can ground out
religion and if it does take a leap of
faith if it really is just just a total
total [ __ ] to to try and ground
morality without God then my argument
would be then maybe it does take a bit
of intellectual acrobatics or a bit of
intellectual ignorance to base your
morality in a godless universe but it
takes less intellectual acrobatics then
it takes to convince yourself that a
loving God exists I think I think
certainly speaking to people about
analogous topics I don't understand I'm
a good avatar for the layperson when it
comes to these sorts of discussions but
it's almost tropi now and very cliche
for people to have this sort of wistful
days gone by view of when things were
better and yeah that's nothing families
stuck together and you had the support
of the church and you had this that any
other I think that certainly seems to me
to be a an argument that is put forward
for this that there was there was just
more social cohesion and and the golden
golden days of when people actually used
to look out for each other all of these
kind of very wishy-washy nebulous tropi
ephemeral sort of claim yet statuses
that get used that I think is what a lot
of people think they're referring to
yeah and look I mean that's that's rose
tinted glasses it wasn't all as good as
you think it was and if you were to be
dropped back in that society maybe it
would be okay depending on who you are
but if you're a gay person you probably
have a pretty horrible time now why is
it that if you went back to this golden
age of morality and social cohesion that
as a gay person you'd have a pretty bad
time is it because of creeping
secularism ruining your life or is it
because of
tyranny saying that you're not allowed
to love the person that you love I think
that's probably the answer like it's
it's it's not I mean the name of society
that has been worsened by throwing off
religious influence in over government
like it can't be done like the the all
of the social progression that you can
think of this because coincided with
secularism every every social
progression has gone forward like
there's nothing that's gotten nothing
that's gotten gotten worse in that in
that sense like I the I I don't know I
mean it really depends on what the
person means specifically when they're
when they when they're answering when
they're asking the question because if
they do actually mean secularism like on
a governmental scale well moral virtue
shouldn't derive from the government
like you shouldn't be being good because
the government they're so because the
church says so moral virtue should be a
private thing you can and and secularism
is just as it just as a secular
government will protect my right to be
an atheist that protect you all right to
be a Muslim or to be a Christian not to
be a Jew so if you think that morality
does need to be grounded in in Judaism
or or Islam or Christianity then the
best way that you can protect your
religious freedom to express that
religious morality is to live in a
secular Sat state that that will not
influence your church like people think
of secularism as the church not
influencing the state it's also the
state not influencing the church it's
about a complete separation so even if
you do think which I don't think is true
but even if you do think that you need
more religion to be a good person then
the best way to protect your right to be
religious is still to live in a secular
society
I had a recently had zubi on the podcast
who's a rapper and actually an Oxford
graduate from back in the day a very
very interesting guy and he's Christian
given the sort of shows that he's on and
the kind of discussions that he has that
was a surprise to me to hear someone who
has those particular worldviews and was
still Christian that was surprising one
of the things that he brought up that I
thought was incredibly interesting was
he said that he feels like people who
are atheists sometimes are more
religious they're more theocratic about
their
atheism than some people who are
religious are about their religion and
he said that he looks at the times that
were in now and sees people trying to
find religion he called it in other
things so he said people try and find
religion in a football team their
favorite football team they're very
religious about their football team or
about their diet about the particular
approach to a diet and I wondered what
your thoughts were on that particular
module in humans for something that
fills that block that religion was in or
is it well if that's true then it's a
criticism of religion it just goes to
show that religion has tried to
monopolize the idea of social cohesion
people aren't striving for religion
they're not striving for some sky daddy
to look after them when they're sleeping
they're looking for connection with that
with their fellow-creatures they're
looking for camaraderie they're looking
for a way to get together and do
something productive for the world and
some people believe that that's throwing
yourself into her into a football
community and supporting a team some
people believe that's by going vegan and
trying to help the world but like it's
got nothing to do with religion and if
you're someone who believes that that is
religion then you've been completely
brainwashed into thinking but the only
way that as soon as somebody is trying
to find friendship and community and do
good in the world that they're being
religious like what are you talking
about if that's what religion is then
practically anything you can do is
religious and any social activity
becomes religious and if everything is
religious then nothing is religious like
to call that religion is to do what you
probably criticize in so many new
atheists or new agey atheists which are
the people who go around and say like
they cool anything their religion they
say like oh I'm not religious I'm like a
spiritual person I I believe in the
earth and like I'm connected to the
trees and things and that's my religion
it's like you're just totally watering
down the meaning of religion like what's
your definition of religion here and a
lot of people criticize it well it's not
so much a criticism of religion but a
lot of anthropologists not so much
anymore but certainly traditionally
speaking a lot of anthropologists
thought that religion grew out of this
like the durkheimian view is of religion
growing out of a
totally it's it's a total social fact
it's completely social in its origin and
it comes from people kind of getting
together and designated things as as
sacred and untouchable and separate from
the rest of society in the same way that
people would do that at a football game
or with a flag or something on
nationalism and the religious get very
annoyed at that they say you know how
could you possibly compare the two like
religion religion comes from Revelation
it comes from true facts about God it
doesn't come from some social
progression or some some made-up stories
like a flag does like us a made-up
concept that we just saw were chosen to
believe in but if this person is saying
that that religion is essentially
equatable with things like that with
things like nationalism with things like
football teams and what does that say
about religion what I thought religion
was supposed to be based upon what's
what's true not what's like socially
cohesive believe did religion just get
first mover advantage how do you mean so
you have this particular module this
particular desire for people to have
this social cohesion yeah and religion
in the same way as the iPhone might not
be the best touchscreen phone that's
available but it was the first one that
got into most people's hands yeah
they're getting grandfathered in is that
what religion did did it get first mover
advantage into this particular structure
well it depends how you define in
religion but I mean yeah it's like the
the earliest kind of forms of religion
that the way that traditional
anthropologists would try and understand
religion is by looking at primitive
religions they go right back to the
beginning and find what is it that they
all had in common before they got all
super complicated with doctrines and
dogma what is the actual essence of
religion what makes a religion of
religion and no one could quite put
their finger on it like no one really
knows religion is a very difficult thing
to define but the I also I don't see how
that is necessarily a criticism of
religion like of atheism I don't have a
problem or atheists don't have a problem
with people people people arguing a case
or or beer or trying to get the
government to do good things like it's
not the problem isn't intrinsically
trying to put your views into into
government action or to try and
proselytize your views
problem is that we don't think those
views are correct like if your views are
correct then of course you should be
trying to to influence the government of
course you should be trying to to
convince other people and be shouting it
in the streets and stuff like that
that's what I'm doing with veganism and
that's the that's the criticism that
would come it's like where you're being
religious about it no I'm not being
religious about it I'm being steadfast
about it I think I'm correct and
therefore I'm trying to argue that
that's the case
and they're doing the same thing it's
like I understand why you're doing that
like if I thought that Christianity was
true I'd be doing everything I could to
make sure that my friends didn't burn in
hell I totally understand your position
yeah my problem isn't that your isn't
that you're arguing your case or that
you're being proselytizing about it but
your that you're being religious about
it my problem is I think you're wrong
that's all like the the the idea that
it's there's some kind of problem with
with shouting your views from the
rooftop like know if they're correct and
that's what you should be doing it's
interesting that first mover advantage
thing and what you're talking about
there that people now with a lot of
things a criticism if you've identified
there your being religious about your
veganism it's that that first mover
advantage and the pervasiveness of
religion as a this matter existence this
this thing which is the first thing of
all of its kind of things requires us to
use everything in relation to that again
they just it's just a word that gets
used and people use religious when they
actually mean something that's a little
bit different than necessarily mean
religion yes but also I mean even if
even if that is what they mean then why
do you think if let's say that is the
case which I don't know if it is but
let's say it is the case that people are
trying to kind of fill that god-shaped
hole like why is that the case do you
think I might have something to do with
the fact that these people grew up in
societies and governments and families
who told them that they're nothing
without the religion that they were born
into that without God they're worthless
that they can't have that there's no
basis for their moral worth if there's
no God like if you're if you grow up in
a society that tells you that your
meaning comes from religion that your
moral worth that the fact that you are
valuable as a human being comes from God
then when you give up that belief of
course you're going to be looking for
something to build that gap because
you've grown up your entire life
believing that there needs to be
something there like
if it is the case that people when they
give up God are desperate to find
something to fill that gap it's just a
testament to how evil people have been
in convincing people that they can't
find moral virtue within themselves that
they can't realize that they have worth
of their own accord that they have worth
because they can experience pleasures
and pain and because they have
preference and because they can be
rational creatures and that it has to be
grounded in some metaphysical nonsense
and that they have to go and make up
some some football team that doesn't
actually exist but it's just an imagined
structure or they have to paint a flag
and invoke some kind of meaning into the
flag or something if that is the case
it's only because people have been told
from the day that they're born that if
they don't do that then they're nothing
well my whole point is that no you don't
need that you can you can find moral
value you can find moral worth without
needing to to make things up you can
ground it and most real and if you have
a morality and a worth that's grounded
in what's real
like there's nothing better than that
there's no there's no criticism that can
they can floor you there's nobody who
can come along and tell you that you're
not worth something or that you're going
to hell because it isn't just a
difference in opinion it's not just your
made-up story versus his made-up story
it's like this is grounded and what I
believe to be true it's not just a
social fact it's it's it's a fact of
nature you know I I don't know I I enjoy
talking to people like that because III
want to see what they mean is it doesn't
really work when you relay a question
like that to me because I'd have to I'd
have to really get to them to the base
of what do you mean by religion what do
you mean by religious what do you mean
by God what do you mean by what kinds of
activities are you talking about what do
you include what you not include but I
think I think it's a false criticism and
even if it is a criticism it's not a
criticism of the truth or falsity of
what exists has nothing to do with
whether religions true or not that's
just a commentary on whether whether
human beings need it or not like even if
it's the case that every human being
really did need religion to be happy
doesn't mean it's true
you should get sue B on the podcast he's
been invited out he's flying out to LA
this week
he's on Rogan next week he's on dave
rubin show the week after that but when
he gets back I'll I'll link you to you
guys in an email I think it'd be really
it'll be a fascinating discussion I'd
love to see you guys go on I think you'd
really get on with him well but Alex
today's been fantastic thank you so much
for your time man can you tell the
listeners if they want to find out more
why should they had of course so cosmic
skeptic is the name and it's quite
specific so pretty much anywhere slash
cosmic skeptic so like Instagram
Facebook YouTube all of that if you just
hit the forward slash cosmic skeptic
I've got all the URLs so that's that's
where to find me but Twitter's probably
the main place to keep up with what I'm
doing fantastic Alex thank you so much
for your time guys if you've enjoyed
this make sure that you check Alex's
YouTube channel out it is fantastic it's
one of my favorites as always any
comments feedback that you have feel
free to get me at Chris will ex wherever
you follow me like share subscribe all
that good stuff but for now Alex thank
you so much for your time of course
[Music]
you